Flesh but have the power to destroy
strongholds.
God did not design to be in bondage to
anything,
to anyone,
to any southern states.
You were made in the image and a
creator,
and that creator is wholeness.
Completeness,
Great Ness.
The only place you can find true freedom
is in the presence of the Almighty.
Today I'm going to give you seven steps
to your breakthrough.
Steps are universal.
You can apply to any area of your life.
Step one
course
that means you got to get along
with
every time you get alone with God,
you give birth to something.
See breakthroughs about persistent.
You got to do whatever it takes to put
yourself in a position to hear God.
God has a crimp to power that your enemy
cannot withstand when in order for you
to access it,
you've got to come into his presence
implementing
in effective ways for your situation now
by your religion.
Retail,
always buy it wholesale.
Go to the original sauce,
the truth,
the place where it hasn't been diluted
hasn't been polluted.
Go to the sauce.
I'm not talking to you about theory
right now.
What I'm telling you was the moment I
started getting alone every single day
with God is the moment my life started
to change.
Now I'm going to close this step out
with scripture so you understand what
I'm telling you is rooted in the word
more.
At 1:35 says very early in the morning
while it was still dark,
Jesus got up
and went off to a solitary place where
he prayed spiritual intimacy window and
impregnates us with the paddle and
needed to get barb to his plane.
Step number two,
detox and emotionally
that this is rooted in Ephesians four,
30 1:32.
It says,
get rid of all bitterness,
rage and anger,
brawling and slander,
along with every form of malice.
Be kind to capacity to one another,
forgiving each other just as in Christ.
God forgave you.
For Kevin,
this is dialysis one I'm telling you to
do with the stem is to examine your
spiritual calls in for traces of the
enemy.
You have to make room for success.
You have to make room for your
breakthrough in your spirit,
which will cause you are full of
resentment and anger,
bitterness or jealousy.
There's no room for success.
There's no room for peace.
Your future is too important to let it
be held hostage by the past.
Let it go.
Now,
when I say forgiveness,
I don't mean that you have to agree with
the wrong done to you.
It just declares that you refuse to be
held in bondage by it.
Any
your future is worth it.
Oh,
worked it,
but that's the goal.
Some of the things that had been done to
you might be so deeply rooted in you
that you can't let go of it on your own.
Now you remember it.
Let's.
Let's look back to that first step that
I told you earlier about getting in the
presence of God daily,
getting alone with God daily,
and you come into his presence and you
laid this bitterness and this anger and
resentment and all the hurts and roles
that have been done to you.
When you come into his presence,
can you lay that stuff on the altar and
say,
Lord,
here it is.
Help me get rid of this stuff.
Tell me,
get rid of anything in the way of your
plan for my life,
but I can hear those chains
falling off where you embrace your
freedom,
your freedom.
You are not a slave in
the breakthrough where we all life
freedom,
trust God with your past.
Give it to him.
Absolute surrender restores absolutely.
Step three for your breakthrough.
You've got to create a powerful vision
for your vickery and your mind.
You've got to be able to see what's your
breakthrough.
Looks like vision as the
greenness breakthroughs must be first.
You can't go someplace
where there is no vision.
The people perish.
Imagination is the womb that will get
better to your future.
They walk through life without a vision
in a constant state of confusion and God
is not in the confusion.
Think outside the box by moving your
mind into the realm of unlimited
possibilities,
but then the construction right now,
creating your mind today that you want
to live in tomorrow to find and in great
detail,
paypal,
what you watch your victory look like,
so you gotta keep your eyes on the prize
and you're fishing in front of you.
It's critical and biblical.
That's your right and down.
Habakkuk two,
two says,
write the vision.
Make it plain so they he didn't read and
can run with it.
Write it down.
Step forward to your breakthrough.
Adopt the mindset of the unstoppable
discipline.
Mine rooted in the truth is the
chiropractor other mind,
every situation,
every trial and tribulation has the
mindset required to overcome it.
Thinking if the stain alone enough will
eventually bring peace and order any
situation.
Now,
let's go to the word we demolish
arguments and every brick tension that
sets itself up against the knowledge of
God and we take captive every thought to
make it obedient to Christ.
To change our behavior,
we must address the thinking that
produces it.
Stop attacking the fruit and get down to
the root.
The word says,
be not conformed to this world,
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind.
Show me your thinking and I will show
you your tomorrow.
Adopt the mindset of a.
It starts right between ears.
The battlefield is over the mind and
you've got to win that every single day
you get on day in and day out.
You can't take a day off.
Your breakthrough must be possessed in
your mind.
Did it there and you have it in a
physical stamp.
Five to clear the breakthrough.
Your mouth is a creative device designed
to call for the food of trump says death
and life on the power to tone.
Those in love is the fruits.
There are some big life,
big factory.
Make the breakthrough.
The words you speak aloud will prove
allegiance to the God you serve.
You either serve in God,
have faith on a condom down the kind of
boldness and courage
and asked for me and my house.
We will serve the Lord.
Declared a breakthrough in your mouth,
mirrors they interstate of your
relationship with God.
Do you believe?
If a person who didn't know you
overheard your conversation,
would they know that you saw?
Would they think that that God you
started has limits on it all takes a
call for things that be not as though
they were the victory.
Step number six,
master the art of blindness.
Bagging doesn't move God.
Faith is the only language spoken in
destiny is obligated by universal love
to concede to the demand of
master.
The Art of blindness.
Doubt is the play.
Naysayers around you must be quarantined
when you're going through trials and
tribulations,
nothing but warriors and soldiers around
you.
You've got to get all those people that
doubt out of your life and your family.
There's people in your family speaking
death,
though when you got to shut them down,
you got to shut down.
All the enemy still has the power and
ability to gain access to the mouth of a
righteous person.
The enemy will use anyone around you to
sow seeds of defeats over your life.
Just like I spoke to you about the last
step about declaring the blessing.
The enemy uses the same principle in
reverse.
He's got to declare and the curse over
you,
and if it can get you to do it,
he will find someone around you to do
it.
So let's go to the war and all things
whatsoever you ask in prayer,
believing you sound real.
Faith is never subject to circumstances.
It's unconditional.
It has nothing to do with your physical
senses.
What you saying what to hear,
what you taste,
what you smell,
how you feel.
None of that.
Faith is more than words.
It's an unconditional activity,
a continuous accident over refusing to
accept what's current circumstances.
I believe in the promise.
I believe in one God says nothing.
Nothing can make me believe otherwise.
Stop focusing on your problems and stay
focused on the two.
Oh,
things
will not change your circumstances.
Faith will step towards.
Faith is a step towards power.
The more you move from making decisions
based on your feelings to data,
true faith,
God's power you will have access to when
expectations and dreams collide,
they explore.
Wouldn't matter if a station is the
oxygen that breathes life into your
dreams.
I'm gonna.
Leave you with one last thing here on
this step is not the length of the
prayer that gives it power,
is the faith behind.
Keep it simple,
ask once and never stopped believing.
The final step.
Number seven,
plug into the power
changes.
Every thing it touches.
God is love and whatever is not love.
It's not of God.
Infinite vibration that reaches to the
core of everything in existence.
It is by far the most powerful thing in
the universe.
Oh,
miracles originated from it.
Powers of nature,
bound to it.
Oh,
success isn't breakthroughs.
Hinge on it.
We overcome not my force.
Mike's Money,
knowledge,
talents we are not because of what we
do,
but because God loves us.
What Jesus did,
my Sauna Cross empowers us by grace to
break through the barriers.
You are God's ambassador owner when a
single agenda and that's to love.
The more fluent you are in this
universal language,
the greater your circle of influence.
Wellbeing is more than just emotional.
It's spiritual ballet act and express it
of this positive energy creates on
occurred in the world and you can
transform anything in your life by
plugging into this frequency,
a plow.
When you in here to the law of love,
you are sending consciousness to the
maximum level of awareness through the
eyes of love.
You will not only be able to see,
but to truly understand being firmly
rooted in his power allows you to
approach life from a place of strength,
but consistently projecting this divine
energy.
Your shits and outcomes become
limitless.
Love is a superhighway.
No the travel on and are destined to
impact the world.
It is the master key that grants access
to the spare room of all creation.
To love is the highest display of
wisdom,
the highest form of trust,
and the highest form of worship.
Shift from a state of needing love,
bleeding,
love,
never in a room with Alex.
never go a day without it released this
catalyst of change I to every
environment you infiltrate.
Instead of wishing for a miracle,
the miracle,
incorporating the gift of love to every
aspect of your life will make you a
difference maker,
your miracle
and the needs of those around you.
The only way to access it is by love.
Love thy neighbor as thyself,
so whatever miracle,
whatever breakthrough you need,
find somebody who needs that same thing
that junee and pray for them,
and they received their breakthrough
secret to the breakthrough resides in
this first show,
40 to 10,
and the Lord turned the captivity of job
when he prayed for his friends.
The Lord gave job twice as much as he
had before praying for others.
It's a catalyst for massive change.
Go get your breakthrough.
I'm Billy Brooks.
Blessed that unstoppable.
The first step to success is to get your
mind right.
The second step is to get your mouth
right.
The words
are a direct reflection of the beliefs
that you have internalized.
I could spend two minutes with you in
conversation and by the words and the
faith that I feel behind those words,
I can tell you exactly what you're going
in.
Life Word set outcomes in motion.
God has given us the power to create
with our mouse.
When you are going through the trial,
the challenge,
the struggle,
whatever it is you're facing,
your mind,
your faith and your mouth are your
weapons.
Success has to be spoken into existence
by either moving you closer
or further away.
I'm going to tell you the secret.
When you learn to tame your tongue,
you take control of your destiny.
You'll get behind the steering wheel.
When your mouth matches your man which
aligns with your faith,
nothing can stop you.
That's what I'm talking about when I say
blessed and unstoppable.
It's so faith your mind and your words
walking in agreement together.
Y'All mail carries full command of the
room around you.
You have the ability to bless,
curse.
He'll destroy every time you order
something out of your mouth.
Acknowledging this transformative power
is essential to building a life of
success rate through in the mind.
What is your mouth that initiates the
change?
In order to seize possession of the
victory,
you have to do that with words so shall
my word be that going forth out of my
mouth.
It shall not return unto me void,
but it still accomplish that which I
please and it shall prosper in the thing
were two half sentence.
Now it's time to declare the blessing.
Every sale,
muscle,
tissue,
ligament,
bone system in my body.
It's bullshit into perfection which God
intended a function I call forth healing
complete rest of the race today and I
will heal then I won't say it the Lord.
My body radiates greatness.
No sickness.
What had dominion over me.
I think like a champion.
I speak like a champion,
a champion,
and when I sit down at the table,
the Food I put in my body helps make me
a better chip.
My body is holding.
My body is the temple of the spirit,
was sad to my body and I will treat my
body with respect every ounce of my
being,
with my message.
I feel I radiate greatness,
not speak over my finances.
Money comes to me easily,
frequently in abundantly.
God's perfect way with no burden added
to it.
Money,
money does that on me.
I own it.
It serves me the head and not the tail.
Above,
not below.
I will lend to many nations and not
borrow.
I am a millionaire,
right?
I said,
I'm a millionaire.
Scarcity,
have no place in the life of a Christian
as explaining his crop,
harvested grain in the planet,
for the Lord blessed him and as well.
Continue to borrow.
Money is coming to me,
pressed down,
shaken together and running over to
overflowing with
every dollar,
with grace and for the betterment of the
kingdom.
I speak over my relationships now.
The right mentors,
coaches,
us,
people who have knowledge that I need
to,
my God and Colin are now coming into my
life.
My marriage is one of unity,
of love.
What a pass one,
a friendship.
We are united together as one under the
one true God.
I speak life over my wife.
Love,
happiness.
Encouragement is for racing,
uplifting everyone I speak.
No sickness has any dominion over the
has no place in her life.
She is prosperous,
successful
in the name of Jesus.
The devil has no place in my home,
my house.
We will serve the Lord United as one.
I refuse to give the devil a foothold in
my life because no corrupt communication
proceed out of my mouth fee.
It has no dominion over me,
but the Lord did not give me a spirit of
fear,
but of power and of love and of sound
mind.
I believe champions don't run from fear.
They attack it.
I'm not in chains.
I'm not in.
I'm not a slave danny anything,
but he who the son sets free is free
indeed,
and I am free.
Alcohol,
drugs last three,
bitterness or jealousy,
unforgiveness,
eating disorders,
panic attacks,
ptsd,
cancer,
heart attacks,
strokes.
None of these things have dominion over
me.
I got goals,
dreams,
and a vision so big,
so massive that it scares me if I say my
intentions.
If I want to collate my destiny out loud
with people around that will be a high
probability that they would attempt to
have me Baker acted on grounds,
that I'm delusional,
that I'm crazy,
that I've lost all sense of reality.
I know don't have the talent,
the ability,
the education,
the natural gifts,
the background,
the connect seems to image the financial
resources to bring my massive ambitions
to fruition,
the truth,
right on the edge of foolishness at the
intersection between genius and
insanity.
I know I'm not qualified,
experienced,
nor clip with the things required to
exceed this level of greatness that
I am bold in this one area
is faith.
I believe not in my own efforts,
in that on the one who is mighty and old
things me,
that his grace is sufficient.
I don't hope that God still moves.
I know he does.
Therefore,
I pick up my five stones for my
slingshot and I fear not the modern take
Elias,
the diocese.
It gives me the walls of Jericho and the
armies and riches come.
Today's pharaohs.
I locked my eyes on the prize and
without any doubt or hesitation or
anxiety,
I'm pressed for waving the banner of the
one true God and I slayed it.
Enemies who whispered doubt and fear in
my ears.
For years,
that same spirit and many claim died off
at the end of the book of acts has
landed on coachable fire deep on the
inside of me to do what the world keeps
on saying it's impossible.
My purpose
bring a claim to the God who
still lives in
Florence,
Alabama,
the son of a modern fandom game minute
DNA process,
wanting me
to the creative.
Now my tail walks with him.
Unleash the power that flows
unrestricted,
unrestrained.
God still moves.
I speak life,
hope and strength through this
microphone to every wounded soul,
broken heart,
the sick Delaine,
the hurting,
the scan,
the fearful,
the last,
the damaged,
the broken.
I am here to tell you,
God still moves.
Oh,
things are possible and I dreamed so big
that it takes the limits off of God so
that he can glorify himself through me.
I average no body.
I surrender and submit every ounce of my
being so that he can use me to inspire
you.
I speak not for likes.
I speak not for subscribers.
I speak not for ad revenue,
no fame accolades or personal validation
grind,
and I come to mountain of success to
bring the one true God of Abraham Glory
and I only pursue my simon fearlessly
attacking the unknown
as the day for me.
I attack going on.
I burned a long time ago.
I only know 1:20
with the type of grind it perseverance
it takes to change the world.
I exemplify the light radiate,
champion and I execute with precision.
The daily actions required to penetrate
the walls and stand against me with a
shout of praise.
Those walls are no match for me,
for God has promised me anonymous and
will deliver me from all the enemies to
stand in the way of greatness.
Now.
God has no keep a persons
what he did for me.
He will do the same for you.
Seize this crisis the same yesterday,
today and forever.
Those miracles to read about it in the
word in the olden days,
they weren't isolated for just one small
time period.
They are valid today and anybody could
faith anybody but trust can see it and
can experience those same type of
miracle.
Now
you're on the phone to
turn this off because I'm here to tell
you,
Steve and you hearing this is no mistake
and it's no coincidence.
God is trying to reach you through this
video,
this video for entertainment.
See
struggling with panic attacks and ptsd
and it's been goes like this that got me
to take this seriously and know where
you're at right now.
When you're listening to me,
just believe
God still moves.
I'm Billy Brooks,
blessed and unstoppable to God.
Be The glory.
When you are anchored in grace,
rooted in purpose,
simply pursuing your colon,
you are blessed and unstoppable.
I am bold because I know I'm in my
colon.
I know the anointing is behind me.
Nothing could stop me.
Arise,
champion.
No weapon formed against me shall
prosper.
My colon is to speak life over the
future champions.
To be successful,
you must seize and conquer every moment,
every opportunity that presents itself
grabbing with both hands and
tomorrow's not promised,
so you don't know if they're going to
get a second chance at this.
So you got to squeeze every ounce of
victory out of every single moment.
God gives you a path for the moments you
got to become a workout more.
You know,
time is down.
You've got a choice either let the day
on you or you own it.
See,
the world has told you a lie.
You'll think success is left.
Somebody else has to put you on.
You got to have all these connections to
go where you want to go,
but I'm here to set the truth straight.
You determine your outcome,
what to do every day,
no work ethic.
Pledge your allegiance to the failure or
success or determine where you go.
Stop waiting for other people to put you
on that,
but so self,
oh,
stop making excuses.
Justice.
Stop observing life and start checking
it.
When you are a good in grace,
rooted in purpose,
aggressively pursuing your calling,
you are blessed and unstoppable is
nothing that makes me sick and then
seeing somebody wastes their gift.
Now I'm not trying to hurt your
feelings,
but sometimes I got to get up in your
face with the truth.
See,
denial will continue to hold you hostage
until you take responsibility for your
actions.
Ignoring the facts were not approved or
circumstances is the practice of the
mind thinking,
sustain long enough will produce success
because I am telling you is straight out
of the word,
to not be conformed to this world,
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind that by testing you made a
song,
what is the will of God and what is good
and acceptable and perfect.
The word always confirms this,
so I'm going to give you another one.
Casting down imaginations and every high
thing that exalts itself against the
knowledge of God and bringing into
captivity every thought to the obedience
of Christ.
That's the mindset of a champion.
That's my message.
God still moves the message to not give
up on your dream.
Your best days are ahead of you.
There's a lot of you out there listening
to me right now that a war years you
just haven't awoken yet,
and guess what?
Ringing the alarm
awaken.
You.
Ain't getting grace rooted in purpose.
Pursue your colon.
Never give up
less than unstoppable
with putting the right things into your
mind.
In my new book,
less than a stoppable was strategically
designed to align your mind with the
laws of success.
This curriculum will teach you to end
mechanics required to go from average to
phenomenal,
from living a life with limits to be
blessed and unstoppable.
As you follow this guide,
step by step amazing breakthroughs.
What happened?
New Doors of opportunity will open and
favor will begin to chase you down to
the unstoppable is a 31 day devotional
on the laws of success.
This book,
what is the gate?
The thought process and actions to
transform your life each day has a Bible
verse,
a teaching on that day,
his principal,
a positive affirmation,
a prayer for the day,
self assessment questions,
success quotes,
action steps in a powerful,
inspirational message regardless of what
field you're in.
Blessed US stoppable show blueprint for
success.
Get your copy and stuff.
Okay.